all right guys
bang bang got scott here thank you so
much for doing this what's up man miami
be here although we both have all black
on which uh
you know the new yorkers all right uh
you've done some incredible work uh with
charity water
but uh you had a whole life before
charity order let's just start there
yeah what did you do for the 10 years
before charity water
well i was born in philadelphia i was
raised in a very conservative
christian home my mom was an invalid
from the time that i was four there was
this weird carbon monoxide gas leak
which is a much longer story
but i really moved to new york city to
rebel against
all of that you know give the middle
finger to the church and the rules
and i found out there was this
remarkable job called a nightclub
promoter where you could rebel in style
and if you were good at this job you
would get paid to drink alcohol
in public you'd drink for free all your
friends would drink for free
so you know to the horror of my parents
and and uh you know the church community
here i am in new york city
uh at the beginning of the bottle
service era
models and bottles as it as it later
became called and so what
you basically are like walking around
new york city trying to meet like rich
people who like to party or beautiful
girls and then get them to come to yeah
basically like a club
yeah basically okay and and if and if
you can put those two things together
you know you also need the right dj the
theme you need to make it interesting
you need to be at the right club
but the promoters uh create the party
the environment and then they just move
so we were
venue agnostic so over the 10 years i
worked at 40 different clubs
so we would come to your club we'd bring
all the people
you know we'd try to ring 50 gs and boos
uh
and then the minute our group got tired
of that club we'd look for the next club
got it and and then you would be able
you know the scarcity
right of not letting people in and the
velvet rope would then allow you to make
a bunch of money to just
charge everybody afterwards so that was
10 years
and look i i was chasing all the markers
of success the car
the watch the model girlfriends the you
know
flying on somebody's private plane to
paris and milan and
busios brazil i mean just it was the
whole lifestyle
and was it fun uh yeah
it was but it you know it was almost it
was almost like the frog and
and water getting boiled so it started
with smoking and then it was two packs a
day and then it was drinking
and then it was gambling and then it was
coke and then it was x and then it was
mdma
and then the next thing you know you
know you zoom out
on your life and i was this despicable
selfish hedonistic sycophantic scumbag
and my tombstone was gonna read here
lies a man who has gotten a million
people drunk
that was the only positive i mean there
was no positive impact there was no
legacy
and i'd actually it was so far of a
departure from
the morality and the spirituality i've
been brought up with so i had this
moment at 28
i was in puente de lesta parting in
south america we'd rented this compound
my girlfriend was on the cover of a
fashion magazine we had a yacht
that came with a compound people serving
us
and i'm like this is this is not how i
want my life to
to be it was like the game of musical
chairs and the music stopped and for the
first time
there was nowhere to sit and i came back
to new york city
i said i'm the worst person i know i'm
spiritually bankrupt i'm a morally
bankrupt i need to start over
and i i sold everything i owned and
tried to start over and the only
idea i had at the time was to try to
find the exact
180 opposite of my life so not as not a
pivot
not a small course correction just
freaking do
everything exactly opposite and my idea
was to go volunteer on a humanitarian
something right to go serve people in
need and see if i could be useful
not serve them alcohol certainly not
certain exactly exactly so
you know you can imagine you know i'm 28
i'm applying to
doctors without borders the red cross
save the children you know these
these organizations i've tangentially
heard of and no one will take me of
course i'm denied by 10 groups
and then finally one organization says
if i'm willing to pay them 500
a month and go live in post-war liberia
then i can join them
so i'm like this is it it's opposite i'm
going to pay to volunteer
and i'm going to the poorest country in
the world at that time that had just
come out of a 14-year civil war
so that was basically what started this
new
chapter uh you probably would not have
wanted to
to to talk to me during the the 10
decadent years
but i i went to west africa i was
immediately
in a country with no electricity no
running water no sewage
i'd never seen poverty before and uh
and i learned half the country was
drinking from swamps and ponds and
rivers
and i'd never seen humans drink dirty
water before
we were joking earlier you know i selvas
for ten dollars a bottle
in clubs and people wouldn't even open
the water they would just order ten
bottles let it sit there and drink
champagne instead
so i learned that you know half the 50
of the people living in the country were
drinking disgusting dirty contaminated
water
and 50 of the disease in the country was
because of bad water
so i wound up finishing a year turning
it into two years
and at the end of two years i was like i
have to do something about it there's a
responsibility
to do something about what i'd seen
specifically this issue
and i came back at 30 and said i'm going
to try i'm going to try to bring clean
water to everybody on the planet
i'm broke uh i'm living on a closet
floor in new york city and
spring and mercer at the time because
i've given all my money to the
the organization and the people i'd met
but i had this very clear
vision that everybody in the world
needed clean water to drink
and so what's the first thing you do
when you come back and you're like i'm
gonna go try to solve this because
that's a really really big goal
yeah so i had so there was something
about having the pictures i'd taken 50
000 photos so my
my role on that um it was actually a
hospital ship
my role was as a photojournalist so i
was paying 500 a month
to take pictures and write stories of
the
the impactful work these humanitarians
were doing so i came back
and i would go out to the clubs at first
and i would open up a laptop and i would
make like six or seven presentations a
night
and people were kicking me out of dj
boost they're like bro you're killing my
buzz
you know just can you just have fun like
i'll give some money to your charity but
like get out of here
so i just did that again and again and
enough people
would give or would make an introduction
um
and i had the advantage of talking to
everyday people
who worked at chase bank or mtv or vh1
at the time or you know the sephora
and or in fashion or music and i
realized
almost all of my friends almost
everybody i talked to
didn't trust charities they were cynical
they were skeptical
they believed charities were opaque and
not transparent they
said well where's my money actually
going how much would even get to
the people that are that are suffering
and
i thought wow this is a huge opportunity
for a paradigm shift for a new business
model
what if a charity could reach out to all
these skeptics and cynics
and say we're going to do things
completely different
and encourage them to give so really the
the big idea when i started charity
water
and this is 14 years ago was just this
very simple promise to use
100 of all donations that we would ever
get
to directly fund projects that got
people clean water
and then in a separately audited bank
account i would go raise the overhead
from you know investors or entrepreneurs
or visionary
um people who knew that they're actually
you need to have a staff and you need to
have an office
but that kind of separation of church
and state was very unique at the time
that then kind of led to this
realization that with non-fungible
business models or two separate accounts
we could use technology
to track where donations went so we were
the first charity just to geo-locate
all of our wells so i could say to you
uh
you know here is exactly where your
donation went here's a satellite image
of your well in malawi or in ethiopia or
in guatemala
and you know we started to just prove
where the money went we could prove
where a nine dollar donation went
and people just loved it you know they
loved this kind of transparency
so we put that together and you know we
we believed that for the work to be
sustainable it had to be led by locals
so we said you know we're going to raise
awareness we're going to raise money as
efficiently as possible
but then it's got to be ethiopians
actually drilling the wells in that
country or
um cambodians in in cambodia so i threw
a party to start it off
at a nightclub that was day one i got
700 people to come
uh i gave them open bar for an hour
and then on the way in there was this
giant plexi cube and you had to
donate 20 to walk in the club and we
collected 15 000
in cash that night we immediately took
it to a refugee camp we did our first
wells and then we sent the photo and
video proof to the 700 people
and we said you came to a party you may
not even remember coming to the party
but you did and you gave 20 and your
money
helped these communities get clean water
and the response was
so kind of overwhelming we said let's
just keep doing this over and over again
let's show people where their money goes
and we can grow the movement and when
you start doing this
do people understand the clean water
problem or are they just trying to like
go to the club go to the party and it
almost like didn't matter if they really
knew where the money was going or not it
was more so just
you knew what it would take to raise
capital and then over time you could
kind of tell the story it was
exactly i think you said it you said it
uh perfectly
um this is not a i remember um
having to speak uh after the head of a
cancer charity once it was a big
conference ten thousand people
and and he walks out on stage and he
says how many people here have had
cancer
and some hands go up and he said okay
how about a family member
more hands up how about a friend or a
loved one the entire audience
and then he starts his speech right it's
not true for dirty water
i mean how many people have had to drink
dirty water or walk eight hours
or you know experience a child dying of
diarrhea
you know because they they drink from a
swamp you know it's nobody
that i talk to so yeah the that became
kind of the first challenge that we
would have to build awareness
i mean you know as we record this 785
million people
are drinking bad water so you know as as
i'm here in miami at a bitcoin
conference
right with thousands of people uh
talking about
you know the state of finance and the
future of
technology like 10 of the world is
drinking dirty water
10 of the world doesn't have the most
basic needs it's just not something
people think about
you know we take water for granted we
take our long showers and we have water
in bottles for convenience and so that's
been that was really the second thing
that we had to do
was create these campaigns these
awareness moments
uh we created psas where new yorkers
would go to central park pond
actually jennifer connolly was in our
first psa and i convinced
terry george from hotel rwanda to direct
it and we put on this like million
dollar commercial for 20 grand balthazar
catered it for free
it was awesome and she takes her
children uh
all the way from tribeca to central park
and she waits in line and she gets nasty
green water and then she gives it to
them
and you know we ran that on uh american
idol to
you know millions of people in a million
dollar donated time slot
and that took over the home page of
youtube uh for world water day so we
were doing all these kind of scrappy
edgy uh awareness building
um you know initiatives that then
started to get people to think about
water a lot of the donors are uh in the
technology community right so investors
entrepreneurs people who work at tech
companies et cetera how did you
get that subset of people interested in
this was it just like one or two folks
and then they kind of brought their
cold email it was the first one uh i had
come across a guy named michael burch
who had just sold bebo
to aol for 850 million dollars
and i just wrote him i said hey i'm a 31
year old kid
i've got a vision to give everybody
clean drinking water
uh i'd love to meet you and he actually
responded and said
okay i'll come into the office and this
is really
we may not even have time for this but
that at that moment i was about a year
and a half into charity water
and i'd raised so much money for the
water projects that was working
the 100 model was working but it was
really hard to raise the overhead
and i had this moment where i had 881
000
in the bank account that i couldn't
touch right that was going to go out and
build 80 wells
and two weeks of payroll and
you know the advice i was getting from
everyone at the time was go
borrow against the 880 you'll pay it
back later you've got to pay your people
you have to make payroll
and i was like no i will shut the
charity down and send the 880 grand out
like if we borrow one penny we have
betrayed the trust of the public like
this
there'll be a crack in the foundation we
should all resign in shame so i was
actually talking to lawyers at that
moment
um this is after the cold email and uh
michael walks in the office at that
moment i remember having what i thought
was a two-hour terrible meeting with him
where he didn't seem to really like what
i was doing and then he left and the
next day he wired a million dollars in
the overhead account
really he said i love what you're doing
it was a year of capital
so we had so that he was kind of like
you know tech
entrepreneur number one then he made a
couple intros
then um i remember speaking at twitter
when there were 48 employees
the very beginning of the company we
were the first charity on instagram
day one um i remember speaking at
facebook's
old university avenue campus so it was
it was the early age of social media and
i just believe that
for us to succeed at our movement we
would have to
grow it online and you know we were
early there so we were the first charity
to get a million twitter followers
uh at the time and and built all these
campaigns so that just kind of led me
from
you know to from i guess jack to michael
burch to johnny ive to reed hoffman to
saka to you know a bunch of these people
and they loved paying for our staff
so when you got the entrepreneur they
actually didn't want their money
going out and building wells they wanted
to hire a ui engineer
or a ux engineer or or a water
program specialist so they got it
because they'd all built
companies so while it was really hard in
the beginning
then these two different value
propositions kind of
began to maybe solidify the public
which is now well over a million donors
from 150 countries
loved knowing that 100 of their money
would go and then business leaders and
entrepreneurs
loved building the thing and knowing
that they were kind of the backers the
builders they were paying the staff and
the people
so you but you have to do these things
in perfect balance and that was the
challenge
too much money in the overhead set
account then you're not efficient
and too much money in the water account
if you missed payroll then the whole
thing
crumbles so it's been it's been a
14-year dance along the way you took how
many bitcoin in as donations
yeah so we were early uh just you know
as i mentioned with a lot of the
technology we were
you know one of the first charities to
use virtual reality for example we
showed it to thousands of people and we
made millions of dollars with our vr
film
bitcoin was the same in 2014 uh tony
hawk gave us 4.8 bitcoin
uh that then later led to 569 bitcoin
all right so tony hawk was early he was
early 2014 he's handing out bitcoins to
people
2014. he came to a gala and i remember
we raised a couple million dollars that
night and he wanted to pay his gala
pledge
in bitcoin and his gala pledge was 1500
bucks
so you do the math i think the math was
312 a coin yeah
so all 569 well maybe just a little bit
of context so when charities take
donations
of any kind the best practice is you
immediately sell whatever you were given
to put it to charitable use right so if
you gave me a hundred thousand dollars
of apple stock
right now maybe to depreciate it there's
a tax benefit for you to do that
i sell it and i go build 10 wells in
your name
that's what you want us to do it's i'm
giving the money to
further the charitable mission so we
treated bitcoin just like any other
stock or property that we're given you
immediately sell it and then you put the
money to work
um but you know the 569 bitcoin we sold
for about four million dollars
and just over the last crazy 30 days
it's 26
to 35 million right so
we helped a hundred thousand people with
all that bitcoin
but we could have helped 600 to 900 000
people
so that's really you know that that
that's where this kind of idea
you know so 500 bitcoin that you sold
for
four to five million dollars four
million four point four million dollars
exactly
4.4 million but it could have been 25 to
35 million
if you had held more in the future
potentially yeah
um and you think you helped a hundred
thousand people
that's enough to help 110 000 people
okay versus
six to nine hundred thousand so six to
nine x
and all you were doing was just
following best practices for sure right
so you know i met um pete briger was
actually the first guy
that kind of got charity water thinking
about this and then i met wences
and you know a bunch of the early people
in the space and the more
i learned about you know both bitcoin
and then also how people think
i said well we're never going to
take in any substantial amount of
bitcoin
for philanthropic use if we follow this
best practice
because people don't want to give you
the bitcoin then have you sell the
bitcoin
into cash because their whole thought
process is that over time
there's a universal i at least i believe
i have experience and again this isn't
my core business i'm running a
at the moment like a 100 million dollar
a year you know annual charity that's
that's
trying to help 2 million people a year
but
everybody has a universal long
appreciating view
of this asset right so nobody thinks
that this is where it peaks
at 38 000 or wherever it is where we're
talking today
however what i found through a bunch of
conversations is if
the charity was willing to hold the
asset
people would be willing to give it now
and let the charity
take the appreciation so that's really
where this kind of idea came from
is could we create a fund that would
hotel bitcoin
for you know a period of time and we
basically said okay at least one full
cycle
2025. we're not going to touch it we're
not going to sell it
until at least 20 25. so give it to us
now
take the tax benefit now right because
if you i mean as you know so many people
i don't even think they think about it
but if they sell they're gonna have to
pay
huge capital gains on on all of it so we
say donate it
to us we will allow it to appreciate
we're gonna
sit on it until at least 2025 allowing
your one bitcoin to be worth you know
a lot more in the future
philanthropically and you get the tax
benefit now
um immediately so that's kind of so that
then you know we had some conversations
you were really helpful
just with with advice and um and that's
that's kind of where we landed so we
were launching something it's called the
bitcoin water trust
um and then we said all right well i
wonder if we can get a hundred people to
do one each like how do you launch
right and then uh we just started making
calls and like hey will you do one will
you do one will you do one
then i said all right well then i wonder
if i can get a match behind it
so can we turn one bitcoin now into two
bitcoin and then we hold both
in the future and then so this started
to work and people started saying yes i
guess you know a lot of the whales it's
but but the whole idea behind this just
so people are clear is the bitcoin water
trust
is part of charity water and
folks are donating in bitcoin yep they
can donate in dollars
or anything else and you'll turn it into
bitcoin at the moment we're working on
building where other coins could go to
bitcoin but the only thing we're holding
is bitcoin okay right now
and then you hold that bitcoin and
you're committed to
not selling the bitcoin for five years
until at least 2025.
okay and the thought process is that's a
full cycle
of uh the havings it's gonna appreciate
between now and then
and you will benefit by holding it just
like a corporation would benefit from
holding on his balance sheet just like
an individual would benefit from holding
it personally
now that power is now uh kind of in your
hands as well
right now we could look stupid so there
is a risk this is a little bit of a
swing
right if we're wrong and all the bitcoin
we
collect today that could have helped
people immediately get clean water
depreciates over time then
we have helped less people get clean
water and that's why charities never do
this
because like who are we to you know to
take any sort of position on anything
so you know maybe just one one last
thing just to jump back on the story so
i've been at this for 14 years now
from that first party at the nightclub
we've raised 550 million dollars
okay so we've raised half a billion
dollars in fiat
and we have incrementalized the
organization from 2 million to 6 million
to 9 to 16 to 23 to 28 to 35 to 45 to 50
to 70
90 million last year 100 million this
year
so it's you know with the largest water
charity in america
but dude we're solving we're
incrementalizing there's nothing
exponential
about my experience over the last 14
years
or really the impact that we're able to
make so we have helped
12.7 million people get clean water okay
700 times okay so it is 700 back-to-back
sold-out shows at the garden it's a lot
of people but
you put it against the problem i'm
trying to solve it's 1
65th so i've done 165. i'm 46 years old
now bro
like i want to solve more than 1.6
of the global problem that i had a
vision to solve
and half a billion dollars just not that
much money i mean there's you know
i probably backstage ran into you know
14 people
that you know have a lot more than that
uh and this is what i worked 14 years
and we're considered one of the fastest
growing charities in the country and
we're considered you know
a picture of rapid acceleration so the
idea here is that
you know i believe bitcoin could provide
an exponential growth story
where because of this strategy people
are willing to give it
both big and small um we had someone's
giving us 50 bitcoin
um actually tyler and cameron are
matching the winkle bosses they're
matching the first 50 bitcoin of this
fund
so i think there's there's an
opportunity for people to you know to
give in a significant way
and then i want people to be able to
give 15 bucks
worth of bitcoin 60 worth of bitcoin you
know 140
and we're you know one of the other
things that you and i were talking about
and you were helpful with
is to the idea is to keep this trust
bitcoin native as well
so we don't imagine in 2025 like just
thinking about this in dollar terms we
actually want to spend the money in
bitcoin
as we start unlocking the trust and as
the bitcoin starts going out
to provide clean water for people
hopefully vastly appreciated
in four and a half five years uh we
don't imagine turning it back into
dollars to then turn into ethiopian burr
or the rwanda and frank the whole idea
is
take bitcoin in hold bitcoin and then
five years from now or more when you go
to
build that well that previously cost ten
thousand dollars
now you spend a tenth of a bitcoin right
or whatever it is
yes and when you do that what you're
actually able to do
is you're able to use a global currency
to accept hold and spend
and do it across all these different
countries but what you're really
benefiting from is the appreciation of
the purchasing power
exactly and you talked about this you
know why should we suffer the same so my
core business
is in us dollars i'm going to raise 100
million u.s dollars
this year from a million generous
individuals all around the world
but you know why should we suffer from
the same depreciation
with our purchasing power as we're
trying to get
human beings clean and safe drinking
water across 29 countries
so i think there's a lot of things not
only can the bitcoin appreciate in price
as as we hold it over a period of time
um you know like if you give me one
bitcoin today
thank you very you very generously
joined the founding group but if i took
your bitcoin today and i sold it i can
give three communities clean water
that's a lot and that's significant and
i'm already doing that you know people
can do that if they want to if they say
no actually i've got a lot of bitcoin
and
i want to help people now we'll still
allow people to do that but i really
believe
in the future it could be 30 communities
with that same bitcoin
and you know would i rather help you
know 30 communities or
10 communities hey guys what's going on
before we continue with this awesome
episode i want to quickly talk about our
sponsor kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as ten dollars
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day track your favorite
project or just simply look at the
trading volume for your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
kraken's been a longtime supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go
and download their new mobile app all
right let's get back into this episode i
hope you're enjoying
this one so the idea is a hundred people
are seeding this with one bitcoin
exactly one myself a whole bunch of
other people that folks would recognize
i don't want to say names they can go on
the website we'll talk about in a second
they can see who's there
uh cameron and tyler going to match the
first 50 so we'll have 150 yep
winklevoss match 50. you're at 150 now
and then the thought process is
that game on anyone in the world who's
listening to this or watching this
on the internet that feels compelled
from
literally you know 0.001 bitcoin
all the way up to 100 bitcoin and we
built a leaderboard i think we're
showing it at 0.0005 or something
okay so you get on the leaderboard if
you give
zero zero five it's on the website okay
it's about 20 bucks
all right and so anyone in the world can
participate here and the idea is to
get bitcoin or dollars converted into
bitcoin sit it in the
bitcoin water trust and that bitcoin
water trust is gonna hold this and it's
gonna have strong hands for five years
and then we're gonna go and we're gonna
start helping people
build these wells but the key being the
goal and there's work to be done but the
goal is to take that bitcoin and pay it
out
to people all over the world in these uh
developing countries
buy these water project materials so if
you're the person doing the construction
the architecture
you know whatever you go by pvc or pipe
or cement or the drilling rigs
yep the the materials needed is all paid
in bitcoin
that's the idea and like you said
there's a long way between now and then
but
you know that's where i think the world
is going and i think we'll we'll have an
opportunity
to help with adoption across 29
countries
as well i completely agree how big do
you think it's gonna get
how big do you want it to get i'd i'd
like at least a thousand
a thousand bitcoin so you know using the
uh you know the the kind of aspirational
goal that a lot of people have with a
million a coin that'd be a billion
dollars
and that would get 20 million people
clean water so again
you know just think so i've been at it
for 14 years
i've helped 12.7 million people
i would love this trust to help 20
million people
through small and large donations and
you know let's say a thousand feels like
a great place to get i think we'll be at
150
when we get through this founding 100
and they give one and unlocks the match
but it'd be great to have all of these
just a huge amount of participation
from around the world a thousand feels
like an awesome place to be
a thousand bitcoin a million dollar
price point a billion dollar
bitcoin water trust that helped 20
million humans 20 million
on top of the 12 and change that you've
already helped
plus what you'll do in the next five
years you'll be somewhere around 50
50 40 50 million people right yeah it's
incredible that's the goal well that's a
dent
that's a bigger den it's a bigger swing
listen there's always the pessimist who
says
oh but you're only helping 40 million 50
million of the 700 million
and then there's the optimist like me
who says well the person who is the
pessimist they're not doing [ __ ]
yeah well we're helping about 5 000 new
people every day
so i'm trying to kind of think of okay
today you know when
i sat with you and i sat through you
know some talks this morning and a bunch
of meetings
like by the time you know from the
morning a full cycle happens
5 000 new people went from dink drinking
dirty water
putting their lives at risk the lives of
their children at risk to clean water
therefore vastly improving their lives
so that yes that's like the kpi
and and i want five thousand to go to
six thousand and nine thousand and
fifteen thousand and twenty thousand
when you think about uh where this puts
charity water moving forward is there a
world where like if this works you then
go to like
all bitcoin or you go
dollars in bitcoin or like you just say
hey we just wanna do it the one time in
the one bitcoin water trust or like
is it too early to kind of understand
what the pathways that are i mean listen
getting a bunch of people this far has
not been trivial
i know my board my finance committee so
you know this this works right now
because i'm continuing to run the core
business
and it's it's interesting the number one
concern
was really cannibalization
and you know as i look at the founding
100 so far like
you know you like what we're doing but
you are going to go write me a 40 000
check and put it in the mail or go on
charitywater.org and drop 40 g's with
your amex
right but you're willing to contribute
to this trust you know
if i think of and i don't want to drop
names but you know 30 of the
you know founding 100 are not interested
in
funding charity water fiat but they're
really interested in this idea
of watching their donation charity water
fiat such a bad name
right but they're interested in the idea
of watching their bitcoin get
doubled and then appreciate over time
also the the website we built is cool
it's tracking at any moment how many
people will get clean water
how much we're holding in the trust and
we're pegging that against a bunch of
currencies against you know the the
pound and the dollar the euro the yen
so it is very kind of see in real time
it's you know we're trying to build a
really transparent flow in 2025 when it
starts going out
will be incredibly transparent and i
think we'll have a great
story for people who gave one bitcoin or
50 bitcoin
or .001 bitcoin of how that appreciated
over time and the people that are being
helped
so we're even pricing now on the website
you'll see we're pricing
the communities and the people served in
bitcoin
not in dollars i think you're on to
something
[Laughter]
for those that are for those that are
listening how can they go figure out
if they want to donate where do they go
sure well uh just charity water.org
slash bitcoin so we made that simple
charitywater.org bitcoin people can go
uh literally just connect the wallets
and yup and you can donate with a tax
receipt
or anonymously or suit anonymously so
you can use your real name
you can make up a name or you can be
completely anonymous
um you know there's a there's a real tax
benefit for
giving bitcoin i think a lot of people
don't know that um
but we you know we've got some of that
on the website as well for people that
just want to understand
and i guess you know the last thing i'd
say is the great thing
about clean water is that everybody
thinks this is a good idea
it's not political it's not religious
right it's the most
basic need in life and
you know that strikes me every once in a
while when i'm sitting in a
in a panel and like i don't know what
the heck some of these people are
talking about because it's just beyond
me
you know and you're sitting here and all
of the opulence and the you know the
open bars and the parties and you're
like
but 10 of the world
is drinking dirty water so i really
hope and believe that bitcoin can be
used as a force for good
in the world that bitcoin can directly
provide human beings on this planet with
the most
basic you could say useful utility
of clean water you know a lot of people
have been there there's an argument out
there
well people don't think it's useful at
all oh it's just funny money it's just
what is the point what is the use of
bitcoin right well i'd like to say
i think we can use it to give 20 million
human beings
the most basic need in life clean water
so that's no brainer
that's a use right and i and i would
hope that other you know non-profits
could start
looking at this as a vehicle maybe not
just to grow their
incremental core business but to take a
big swing
and to go out to a donor and i mean i've
heard from so many of these whales and
like yeah i don't give
to these donor advice funds they're just
gonna turn it so i'm holding it on i'm
holding it all
well is that donor gonna give to you in
five years maybe maybe
not maybe they've moved on maybe they
found another passion maybe they found
another cause
so i think that's that's what we're
trying to do here is
both uh honor the intent and the
long-term
appreciating value view while
also saying please give it to us now
please make this donation now
let us custody it and we'll we'll create
a really big
impact story i'm in
i appreciate it i know i think this is a
no-brainer um
i think that you're not gonna get enough
credit for how hard this has been
uh i also don't think people understand
how impactful
if it works right if i think it will
but if it works what is today
you know whatever uh be about a hundred
million no actually it would be uh what
less than 50 million dollars donated in
becomes a billion dollars it's a pretty
big deal
yeah right you know what 40 50 million
bucks that goes in
and then in five years you hand out a
billion
seems to me like uh that's a a pretty
good upside downside trade
yeah i i think so and and i think you
know charities don't take
enough risks and that's just another
thing that you know we just want to
encourage
people know what risks are taking we
were talking right before we started
about
you know we we know people that were
billionaires and then they lost it all
and then they became billionaires again
and then they lost it all
right and and i told you i know somebody
who did it three times
and you know certainly like charities
had like stewardship is
is so so important to us and
transparency and
and being great stewards um and
none of those values should go away but
charities need to think big i mean we
just
we need to uh get tired of the
incremental complacency and these
problems are so big
like we're the largest water charity in
the country and i'm gonna help 1.7
million people
out of 7.85 this year that's not enough
it's not enough with all the abundance
in the world with all the capital
that is out there so it's i think it's
up to us to be creative
to be bold to ask people to move it from
their coinbase and their gemini
gemini wallets or their you know the all
the
from from cold storage to the
i mean to the mouths of people with
clean drinking water
like to all you know you pick the cause
but there's so much suffering
suffering going on right now that does
not need to be
you know and and it is our job i think
as non-profits to
encourage people to be generous you know
we talked on the phone once about kind
of having enough i mean
one of the struggles with this whole
project is nobody wants to give up their
bitcoin
so we have to make the issue of human
beings getting clean drinking water
trump everybody's like you know desires
to accumulate more
a little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more um and
and i think that's
i don't even know exactly how to do that
yet except telling the story
uh being as passionate as i can about
just helping
people helping people thrive
and flourish through the most basic need
clean water and trying to use bitcoin as
a force
to to enable that as you've seen uh
bitcoiners
are uh relentless
in their pursuit of acquiring more
bitcoin but
when they understand the cause is
important or they see
some way that they can help they're some
of the most generous people in the world
as well
and i think it's a really unique kind of
balance between those two things so
you're doing a great job
and the philanthropists of the future i
believe will come
from this community the greatest
philanthropist in the future
uh i think the most radical acts of
generosity
uh maybe even impulsive and i think
that's okay you know
right some sometimes like people build
these huge foundations and
layers and layers of bureaucracy and
grant writing
i think there are you know extraordinary
people in this community that can go see
a problem and say not on my watch
i'm going to solve that i'm going to
make an extraordinarily
radical generous gift and i am going to
just
change a million lives change 10 million
lives
whether it's our issue or whether it's
others that people come across so
that's that's what really excites me
about all the people that i've met and
there's a little wariness there's a
little scent you know cynicism and
skepticism i think when it comes to
anything institutional
but we believe we can bring a highly
effective highly transparent vehicle
to the community um you know we can we
can really make
an exponential dent in in the global
water crisis
i think you are on to something my
friend where can we send people to find
you on the internet
uh i'm just scott harrison at scott
harrison on twitter it's twitter's best
place yeah
what what's bigger for you twitter and
twitter twitter all right and then
charity
instagram is family stuff nobody nobody
cares about my kids
bitcoin charitywater.org bitcoin all
right if you're listening
charitywater.org
bitcoin 0.005 or so
bitcoin gets you on the leaderboard uh
bitcoin's been good to you
go check it out see what it's about when
you see the website you're gonna be
goddamn it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool that's pretty cool and
then you will uh your team put the
website together in two weeks too
so it's you know that's another thing we
believe it is just agility and we've got
a great team at charity water they work
really hard and
uh 100 goes directly to help people so
there's no overhead
um every single bitcoin every single
fractional bitcoin
will go straight to help people get
access to clean water
well i appreciate all the effort and uh
i think bitcoiners have come through
so thanks for joining us you've been a
big encouragement and a big help to me
that means a lot you're doing a great
job all right thank you so much for
doing this we'll do it again in the
future